this is an unnecessarily rushed
explanation of the best music game of
all time
Elite Beat Agents so in Japan
cheerleaders aren't really a women
they're actually dies dies run a lot of
cheer squad versus game up for the
Nintendo vs in Japan called Osaka Kyoto
and Nam means hey fight cheer squad
bunch of male cheerleaders cheering on
people in their everyday lives soon to
be the Japanese pop song this is one of
the absolute best games of the Nintendo
DSi
nvs is a touchscreen and so what you do
is you tap on the touch screen to the
beat of the music it is super it's it's
really easy to get into but it's also
really hard at the same time in
community to knock the levels up the pop
songs are great there's this wonderful
anime aesthetic through the whole entire
thing very very clever story so anyway
none of this stuff translates well into
the United States of America right I
mean the idea of the all-male male she
responded this we didn't sense the idea
of you know Japanese pop songs not
really popular he or so for America they
call the game Elite Beat Agents encoded
in a total revamp of the entire thing
the guys are like the men in black
instead of the cheer squad so basically
the men in black show up and cheer on
people in their everyday lives and then
the entire thing is set to songs like
the Jackson 5 and Madonna and all that
kind of good stuff for America and it
works perfectly
having the beat of the views
and ODS so I like music games you
absolutely got to try these games for
the NES a weekly basis or Osaka kayo
when Don in Japan they're so good
best nice game